well certainly the big big issues are
hunger environmental and peace the
biggest challenges are to respond to
hunger and make sure that the whole
world is fed peace is the understanding
of an appreciation and acceptance of
each other's cultures beliefs and
individuality and of course to work
together to make sure that we do not
destroy the hand that feeds us the major
issue of the election and what is sort
of concentrated in the united states i
think is our role in the world peace and
maybe focus more on alleviated
alleviating some of the hunger and some
of the hardships of people around the
world and also internally their
nutritional issues children and eating
right and obesity and obesity and
understanding and the production of food
that it is real food I think America is
unquestionably the number one country
leader the whole world world is looking
at us for ideas help so unquestionably
we are the dominating force in the world
and it's a responsibility that really
sometimes cannot be taken not sometimes
it can not be taken lightly and we need
to work at it all together
of course for me I think that Italian
food is just the perfect food second to
that I think that Chinese food or
oriental now that all the small
individual cuisines have opened whether
it's ty whether it's Vietnamese is the
second now Italian is maybe because I
know what the best but i think its
nutritional it just makes sense a
flavorful it's a cuisine of joy and
pleasure and positive and communicating
and collaborating in the family it just
is all that food should be